This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目专注于黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全但却坦诚相见的对话，而陪你聊这些的则是一位懂行的持证专业人士。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做。点击收听《知难而进》，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。搜索数字“2%”，即可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
相信闺蜜，宝贝，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回首往事》（The Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说都是一个重大的时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost,
我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家。比如在探讨80年代时请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。不过，你可能已经注意到了，今天的节目是一期重播。所以在接下来的两周里，我将播出过去四年几乎不间断录制节目中，
non-stop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me talking about it, but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book.
我最喜欢的一些精彩单集，因为我要抽出一些时间来发布我的首部新书《成长中的人：你二十多岁时的心理学指南》（Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s）。不用担心，我将在4月29日回归，但我只是想在接下来的两周里给我的书多一点额外的关注，因为这是一件大事，而且我也不会过多地谈论它。我确信你来这里只是为了听播客，可能也听腻了我一直在谈论它，但我只想说谢谢。我要对允许我写这本书的你们表示由衷的感谢，
book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. That's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me. So just thank you. Thank you so much.
并把它带到这个世界上。这一切只有靠你们，靠你们这些听众才能实现。就是这样。这就是我能做到这一点的唯一原因。我从五岁起就想成为一名作家，20年后。你们帮我实现了这个愿望。所以，谢谢你们。非常感谢。
I would obviously love it if you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much. and I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. Most of all, I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it. I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love Person in Progress as well, but it's a really exciting time and the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much.
如果你能预购、购买或把它作为礼物送给朋友，我当然会很高兴。但你们已经做得很好了，能有这次机会我深感荣幸。最重要的是，我真的非常期待你们去读这本书。我希望你们能有所收获。我相信，如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢《成长中的人》，这是一个非常激动人心的时刻，我现在的最大感受就是感激。所以非常感谢大家。
Without further ado, I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Worrying about what other people think about us can take up a lot of mental real estate. We kind of know that we shouldn't care.
废话不多说，希望大家喜欢我这期有史以来最喜欢的重播节目。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁时的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时经历的重大生活变化与转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。因为我们当然要剖析二十多岁时的心理学。担心别人对我们的看法会占据我们大量的心理空间。我们其实知道自己不该在意。
We know that we are loved. We know that no one is really watching us that closely. But for some of us, it's not really a choice. We are overwhelmed by this deep, persistent fear of being perceived. We're constantly aware of those invisible judgments that other, might be making, what parts of us they might not like, who we might offend, if we say the wrong thing, who we make cringe, and it keeps us in this place of self-denial, denial of our true selves, of our potential, of our ambitions, of our authenticity. And today, I want to talk about
我们知道自己是被爱的。我们知道根本没有人会那么仔细地盯着我们看。但对我们中的一些人来说，这其实并不是一种选择。我们被一种对“被注视”的根深蒂固、挥之不去的恐惧压得喘不过气来。我们时刻都在意那些别人可能正在做出的无形评判，在意他们可能会不喜欢我们的哪些部分，如果我们说错了话会冒犯到谁，会让谁感到尴尬，这让我们陷入了一种自我否定的状态——否定真实的自我、否定我们的潜能、否定我们的野心、否定我们的真实性。今天，我想谈谈
it, because it's a fear that is definitely not spoken about enough, despite being something that a lot of us in our 20s and beyond manage on a daily basis. Being in this decade of life, it comes with a lot of insecurity for sure, you know, it's our first decade of adulthood and we're normally lost, we're lonely, maybe we're trying to fit in. And this fear of being perceived feeds on these worries to make us feel even more out of place and insecure. What you may not know is that there is a lot more to be said about this than just the typical explanation that we we get of social anxiety or low self-confidence. Our fear of being perceived has its roots in early experiences of social exclusion, bullying,
这个话题，因为这绝对是一个没有被足够重视的恐惧，尽管我们中许多人在二十多岁甚至更大人群中每天都在应对它。处在这个年龄段，无疑会伴随着许多不安全感，你知道的，这是我们步入成年的第一个十年，我们通常感到迷茫、孤独，也许还在努力融入群体。而这种对被注视的恐惧会利用这些担忧，让我们感到更加格格不入和缺乏安全感。你可能不知道的是，关于这一点，除了我们通常听到的社交焦虑或低自尊之类的解释之外，还有很多值得探讨的地方。我们对被注视的恐惧，其根源在于早期社交排斥、霸凌的经历，
even perfectionism and how our brains process social and emotional information. Learning about this really helps us accept this reality that has kind of been thrust on us, right? And with that knowledge comes power, the power to kind of change the thought loop that keeps us fearful and withdrawn and when you break down the irrational and fear-dependent thoughts that keep us trapped by other people's potential judgments, a huge weight is really lifted. And that's really what I want for you. We're also going to discuss three powerful mental shifts that I've used that are backed by research and psychology that can help you overcome your fear of being perceived, from
甚至是完美主义，以及我们的大脑如何处理社会和情感信息。了解这一点真的能帮助我们接受这个强加给我们的现实，对吧？而伴随着这种认知而来的就是力量，一种能够改变那种让我们感到恐惧和退缩的思维循环的力量。当你剥离掉那些由于担心别人潜在的评判而让你陷入困境的非理性且受恐惧支配的想法时，你真的会感到卸下了千斤重担。这正是我希望为你们做到的。我们还将讨论我用过并在研究和心理学支持下的三个强大的心理转变，它们可以帮助你克服对被注视的恐惧，从
playing mind games with your mind games to decentering the opinions of others through exposure and also applying one of the greatest cognitive tricks of all time to essentially stop your anxiety about other people's opinions before they even begin. There is so much to talk about and I also want to explore what can happen when we do this. What is the reality of being free from our fear of being perceived? so much becomes possible. I just think it's something that a lot of us can't even imagine, but I kind of want to show you what that might look like.
用心理战来对付你的心理战，到通过暴露疗法将他人的评价去中心化，以及运用史上最伟大的认知技巧之一，从根本上在对他人评价的焦虑开始之前就将其制止。有太多内容要探讨了，我还想探讨当我们做到这一点时会发生什么。摆脱对被注视的恐惧究竟意味着什么？会有无限可能。我只是觉得这是许多人甚至无法想象的，但我想向你们展示那会是什么样子。
So there is a lot to unpack in this episode, and I know from hearing from all of you that this is not uncommon in the slightest. So for all of you who are managing this, dealing with this episode is for you to get that clarity, to feel seen, to know the psychology, and of course to overcome it. So without further ado, let's get into how you can overcome your fear of being perceived. Our fear of being perceived really comes down to this irrational anxiety around being observed and scrutinized by others. It's kind of in the name, really. But this fear is also known as scopophobia, and that comes from the Greek word scope to be examined,
所以这一集有太多内容需要剖析，而且从你们大家的反馈中我知道，这绝对不是什么罕见现象。所以对于所有正在经历、正在应对这一问题的人来说，这一集就是为了让你们获得清晰的认知、找到被看见的感觉、了解其中的心理学原理，当然，还有克服它。那么废话不多说，让我们来看看如何克服你对被注视的恐惧吧。我们对被注视的恐惧，归根结底是对被他人观察和审视的那种非理性的焦虑。其实名字里就已经说明了一切。但这种恐惧也被称为视线恐惧症（scropophobia），这个词源于希腊语“scope”，意为检查，
and of course, phobia to fear. Anytime something contains the word phobia in it, we know that what's really happening below the surface is anxiety. There is a dysregulated response to a persistent, irrational thought or worry. You might say, you know, okay, scropophobia, yeah, it has its own name, but isn't this just social anxiety? And you would be totally right for thinking that the fear of being perceived and social anxiety often go hand in hand. but this is more than simply a social phobia around wanting to avoid being seen by others. It's also a specific phobia and specific phobias surround an extreme fear of a specific situation that poses little to no danger but makes people really, really anxious.
当然还有“phobia”，意为恐惧。每当一个词包含“phobia”时，我们就知道在表象之下真正发生的是焦虑。这是对某种持续存在的、非理性的想法或担忧的失调反应。你可能会说：“好吧，视线恐惧症，是的，它有自己的名字，但这不就是社交焦虑吗？”如果你这么想，完全没有错。对被注视的恐惧和社交焦虑通常是相伴相生的。但这不仅仅是一种想要避免被他人看到的社交恐惧症。它也是一种特定恐惧症，而特定恐惧症围绕着对某种几乎没有危险或根本没有危险特定情境的极端恐惧，但却会让人感到非常非常焦虑。
The thing is, your fear of being perceived can be isolated to just a single environment. Like you may have no trouble public speaking, hosting parties, even being seen by strangers on the street, but when it comes to dating, you are incredibly fearful of what people might think of you on your first date or on dating apps, so you avoid those situations altogether. That's a specific trigger for your phobia of being perceived. Or you may be really confident in every other setting other than in the workplace or at the gym. That's why this fear can be very specific in nature. It's at this point that it's probably important to note that there are kind of two versions or two varieties to our fear of being perceived.
问题在于，你对被注视的恐惧可能只局限于单一的环境中。比如你可能在公开演讲、主持派对、甚至在大街上被陌生人看到时毫无压力，但一到约会时，你就极其害怕别人在初次约会或约会软件上对你的看法，于是你干脆彻底避开这些情况。这就是针对你视线恐惧症的一个特定触发点。或者除了在职场或健身房之外，你在其他任何场合都非常自信。这就是为什么这种恐惧在本质上可以非常具体。此时，可能同样重要的是要指出，对于我们对被注视的恐惧，其实有两种版本或两种类型。
There is the fear of being physically perceived, taking up space, being seen by others, which is probably the most common. And then there is the fear of being emotionally perceived, which has more to do with being seen deeply and intimately by someone else on a more kind of feelings-based level. It's less common, but it's still a really real. really difficult reality to believe that if anyone were to truly see you and your character and to know you, they probably wouldn't want to be around you anymore. Physical, like our fear of physical perception is more around people making assumptions. Oftentimes, though, they kind of go hand in hand because perception alone isn't scary, right? It's the judgment that comes next.
一种是对被物理感知、占据空间、被他人看到的恐惧，这可能是最常见的。还有一种是对被情感感知的恐惧，这更多地关乎被另一个人在更深层次、更亲密、更偏向情感的层面上看透。这种相对少见，但却是一个非常真实、非常痛苦的现实——让人觉得如果任何人真正看清了你、看清了你的性格并了解了你，他们可能就不会再想和你在一起了。物理上的感知，就像我们对物理感知的恐惧，更多是围绕着人们做出假设。不过通常情况下，它们是相辅相成的，因为仅仅被感知并不可怕，对吧？可怕的是随之而来的评判。
And that is where kind of the emotional element comes in. it's not that we kind of think that someone looking at us is inherently dangerous, that their eyes are going to like burn holes in our skin, even if it might feel that way sometimes. It's what we know comes second. People make instantaneous and snap calls around what they think someone is like within seconds or minutes. And perception is not objective. There is not one clear way of seeing everything and everyone, it's subjective. So we can't control what they think about us, whether that is correct or not. And that is often what is really at the root of this experience. We don't actually fear the act of being perceived physically. We fear being judged, and we fear
这正是情感元素介入的地方。并不是说我们觉得别人看着我们本身有多危险，觉得他们的眼光会在我们的皮肤上烧出洞来，尽管有时感觉确实如此。而是因为我们知道接下来会发生什么。人们会在几秒钟或几分钟内，根据他们对某人样子的看法，做出即时且仓促的判断。而且感知并不是客观的。看待每件事和每个人并没有一个清晰的标准，它是主观的。所以我们无法控制他们对我们的看法，无论这种看法是否正确。而这往往才是这种体验的根源所在。我们实际上并不害怕被物理感知的行为。我们害怕被评判，我们害怕
the unknowns that are contained in those judgments. And here is where we kind of return to that distinction between fear and anxiety. Fear is for the present and anxiety is for the possibility. That's where all the fun is in for our anxiety, right? Our anxiety likes to try to figure things out that we may never know and that unknown is so scary. We catastrophize based on the worst case scenario rather than what is most likely, which is that people pay a lot more attention to themselves than anyone else. Most people are actually fairly kind with their judgments. And even if they aren't, we're still going to be okay. We can survive someone not liking us based on limited information.
这些评判中所包含的未知。在这里，我们又回到了恐惧（fear）和焦虑（anxiety）之间的区别。恐惧是针对当下的，而焦虑则是针对可能性的。这正是我们焦虑的乐趣所在，对吧？我们的焦虑总是喜欢去琢磨那些我们可能永远无法知道的事情，而这种未知是如此可怕。我们会基于最坏的情况而不是最可能的情况来进行灾难化想象，而最可能的情况其实是——人们花在自己身上的注意力远多于任何人。大多数人在做出评判时其实都相当善良。即便他们不是，我们也会没事的。我们可以熬过别人因为信息有限而对我们产生的不喜欢。
We can survive someone not liking us based on their own insecurities because it's not about us anymore. But let's kind of track back for a second because there is something crucial I've missed here that is, what is it exactly about those invisible judgments that are so scary for people with a fear of being perceived? Yes, it is the fact that it is an unknown which our anxiety thrives on, but it also is a little bit more than that. Social judgment holds a lot of power because of our innate ingrained fear of social disapproval. We don't want others not to like us. We don't want them to think that there's something wrong with us. We don't want them to walk away from meeting us or hanging out and go and say terrible things that might ruin our reputation or destroy.
我们可以熬过别人因为他们自己的不安全感而不喜欢我们，因为这已经不再关乎我们了。但让我们暂且回过头来看看，因为我在这里漏掉了一个至关重要的问题，那就是：对于有“被注视恐惧症”的人来说，那些无形的评判究竟有什么可怕的？是的，事实是那是一个未知数，而这正是我们的焦虑得以滋生的土壤，但它其实还不止于此。社交评判之所以握有巨大的权柄，是因为我们内心深处对社会不悦（social disapproval）的根深蒂固的恐惧。我们不希望别人不喜欢我们。我们不希望他们觉得我们有什么毛病。我们不希望他们在与我们见面或相处之后离开，然后去说那些可能会毁了我们的名誉或摧毁
certain relationships. This is really the case for a few reasons. Firstly, we kind of fear others' opinions out of a need to protect our self-esteem and to continue to validate ourselves. We don't want people not to like us because that might hurt our sense of self-worth. I think we all know what it's like to be confronted with an ugly truth about what someone else really thinks about us. if it's a former friend calling you cringe, an ex thinking that you're lame or unattractive,
某些关系的糟糕的话。造成这种情况的原因其实有几个。首先，我们害怕别人的意见，是出于保护自尊和继续自我验证的需求。我们不希望别人不喜欢我们，因为那可能会伤害我们的自我价值感。我想我们都知道，当不得不直面别人对你真实看法的残酷真相时是什么感觉。比如一个曾经的朋友说你很尴尬，一个前任觉得你很无趣或没有吸引力，
you know, some asshole on the internet or from school, whatever. When someone makes a snide comment about your looks, about any feature of you, that really hurts. And we want to avoid that hurt. And we want to avoid the damage that it does to our self-esteem. So we begin to fear those judgments as a way to avoid them. But let's dissect that even further. if someone doesn't like you, then what? Well, for our anxious mind, if people don't like us, they think we're unattractive,
你知道的，或者是互联网上或学校里的某个混蛋，诸如此类。当有人对你的外表、你的任何特征做出贬损的评论时，那真的很痛。而我们想要避免那种痛苦。我们想要避免它对我们自尊造成的损害。所以我们开始害怕这些评判，以此来逃避它们。但让我们进一步剖析这一点。如果有人不喜欢你，那又怎样呢？好吧，对于我们焦虑的大脑来说，如果别人不喜欢我们，觉得我们没有吸引力、
annoying, whatever your primary insecurity is around being perceived, we worry that as a secondary consequence of that, we will lose really valuable relationships or opportunities for connection. That's a really primal instinct you have going on there. You don't want to be left out of the group. You want to avoid isolation and loneliness at all costs because our ancient brain knows that could harm us in the long run. Basically, this is our fear of rejection, kind of working in tandem with our desire for social acceptance and belonging. But actually that ends up driving a wedge between us and other people anyways, because we end up, you know, letting this fear drive us to self-isolate, drive us to not put ourselves out there, to not really connect with people, which means that although
令人讨厌，或者不管你对“被注视”的核心不安全感是什么，我们都会担心，作为这一结果的次要后果，我们将失去真正有价值的关系或建立联系的机会。你内心深处正运转着一种非常原始的本能。你不想被排除在群体之外。你希望不惜一切代价避免孤立和孤独，因为我们古老的大脑知道，从长远来看，那会伤害我们。基本上，这就是我们对拒绝的恐惧，与我们对社会接纳和归属感的渴望并存着。但事实上，这最终还是在我们和他人之间打下了楔子，因为我们最终还是（你知道的）让这种恐惧驱使我们自我孤立，驱使我们不敢展现自我，不敢真正与人连接，这意味着尽管
our fear of being perceived might in our brains be protecting us from being embarrassed, from being excluded, from being teased or mocked, and therefore protect our social relationships, actually it's having the counter-effect. And it's meaning that we tend to close ourselves off from those opportunities anyways. It's like if you begin to expect that people won't like you or will immediately think the worst of you, why give them the power to even do that when you can stop that from happening in the first place by never showing up? You can't be perceived if you're not present. And so we tend to reduce our anxiety and our fear by reducing exposure to the trigger, which is other people or situations where we think we might be uncomfortable.
我们在大脑中对被注视的恐惧可能在保护我们免受尴尬、免受排斥、免受戏弄或嘲笑，从而保护我们的社会关系，但实际上它产生了相反的效果。这意味着我们往往还是会把这些机会拒之门外。这就好比，如果你开始预料到别人不会喜欢你，或者会立刻把你想得最坏，既然你可以从一开始就通过“永远不露面”来阻止这一切发生，为什么还要给他们这样做的权力呢？只要你不在场，你就不会被感知。因此，我们往往通过减少对触发因素的暴露来降低我们的焦虑和恐惧，而这个触发因素就是其他人，或者是那些我们认为自己会感到不舒服的场景。
I think we know all too well that this avoidance typically backfires, as avoidance always does when it comes to phobic behavior or anxiety. The less exposure you have, the more power your fear has, because it begins to make everything seem worse in your brain, and you have no lived experience to prove otherwise. Like in this example, right, you believe that if people could perceive you, they would say something mean or cruel or would think that you were embarrassing and that would result in them not liking you, bad-mouthing you, having a negative judgment. The outcome of that is super scary.
我想我们都太清楚了，这种逃避通常会适得其反，就像面对恐惧行为或焦虑时逃避一贯的做法那样。你暴露得越少，你的恐惧就拥有越大的权力，因为它开始让一切在大脑中显得更加糟糕，而你却没有任何生活经验来证明并非如此。就像在这个例子中一样，对吧？你认为如果人们能注意到你，他们就会说刻薄或残酷的话，或者会认为你很尴尬，而这会导致他们不喜欢你、说你的坏话、对你产生负面评判。这种结果太可怕了。
You can't handle that possibility and so you never let it be the case. But in your efforts to reduce your anxiety, which is a totally natural thing to do because anxiety obviously makes us uncomfortable, we actually never question or give ourselves the opportunity to disprove this irrational hypothetical. Worse than that, we never give ourselves the opportunity to prove to ourselves that we are capable of feeling judged and pushing forwards anyway. We never get to prove to ourselves that we are bigger than what someone may or may not think. We can experience our worst fear and we can survive. it and we can not just survive, but it can fuel us and it can make us bigger and better,
你无法承受这种可能性，所以你永远不让它发生。但在你试图减少焦虑的努力中——这完全是一件很自然的事情，因为焦虑显然让我们感到不舒服——我们实际上从未质疑过，也从未给自己机会去证伪这种非理性的假设。更糟糕的是，我们从未给自己机会向自己证明：我们有能力感受到被评判，并且无论如何都能继续前行。我们永远无法向自己证明，我们比别人可能或不可能怎么看我们要更强大。我们可以经历我们最恐惧的事，并且能够存活下来。我们不仅能存活下来，它还能激励我们，让我们变得更宏大、更好，
and in some ways it actually reduces the initial fear that we had. So what are the consequences of this? Well, I've kind of seen it in myself, to be honest. In the past, I remember self-abandoning, a lot denying my true self, kind of the opportunity to be vibrant and present because the fear was louder than my impulse to express myself and made me very, very small and very, very sad. At first, I remember this very clearly, like I'd be really excited to, I don't know, post a picture online or to express my opinion or to go to this party and talk to people or even just like create something cool and interesting and share it. And then this fear would infiltrate and make all those positive feelings and all that
并且在某种程度上，它实际上减少了我们最初感到的恐惧。那么，这一切的后果是什么呢？老实说，我在自己身上也看到过这一点。过去，我记得自己经常自我抛弃，大量否定真实的自我，放弃了展现活力和当下的机会，因为恐惧的声音比我表达自我的冲动更响亮，这让我变得非常非常渺小，非常非常伤心。起初，我对此记忆犹新，我曾对——我不知道——在网上发一张照片、表达我的意见、去派对和别人聊天、甚至只是创造一些酷炫有趣的东西并分享它，感到非常兴奋。然后这种恐惧就会渗透进来，把所有这些积极的感受和所有的
anticipation, it would wilt it. It would make it really, really small. And you push down the parts of you that you think are too much, or that stick out a little bit too much. You avoid situations that you probably would have enjoyed and you deny yourself opportunities. Because a lot of opportunities do come with perception. The more successful you become, the more passionate you become, more people begin to notice you. And of course, if you can't have handle that perception, why ever put yourself in a position where you could be praised or you could be seen? I think simply put, the desire to fit in and the paralyzing fear of being disliked, it undermines our ability to pursue the lives we want to create. The hypothetical views of people
期待感都消磨殆尽。它会把这一切变得非常非常渺小。你会压抑掉自己身上那些你认为“过于张扬”或“过于突兀”的部分。你会避开那些你本会享受的情境，剥夺自己的机会。因为许多机会确实伴随着被关注。你越成功，你越充满激情，就会有越多的人开始注意到你。当然，如果你无法应对这种关注，又为什么要让自己处于可能受到赞扬或被看见的地位呢？我觉得简单来说，融入群体的渴望和对被人讨厌的麻木恐惧，正在侵蚀我们追求理想生活的能力。那些我们甚至不在乎、更谈不上了解的人的
we don't even care about, let alone know, take on more power than our own intentions and our own dreams. It's really interesting because as one person put it to me, it's kind of like you put a wall between you and the world and you both resent that wall, but you also rely on it at the same time. At an extreme, our fear of being perceived can cause us to panic and experienced heightened levels of social anxiety, terror, dread, shortness of breath, shaking the urge to go and hide, you know, and it's often in response to specific situations, like being introduced to new people, being in large group settings where you feel like the Yop one out, being the center of attention. So a question I've definitely asked myself, and I'm sure you may have as well,
假想观点，竟然比我们自己的意图和梦想拥有更大的权力。这真的很有趣，正如一个人对我说的那样：“这就好比你在自己和世界之间筑起了一堵墙，你既痛恨这堵墙，但同时又依赖着它。”在极端情况下，我们对被注视的恐惧会导致我们恐慌，并经历高度的社交焦虑、惊恐、恐惧、气短、颤抖、想要躲藏的冲动（你知道的），这通常是对特定情境的反应，比如被介绍给新认识的人、身处感觉自己像个局外人的大型聚会、成为关注的焦点。所以我肯定问过自己一个问题，我相信你可能也问过自己：
why does some people have this fear and others don't? There are people who are just not afraid in the slightest to exist as their fullest and truest selves. and we really admire them for that. I'm sure we all have someone in mind right now. Maybe it's like a pop culture figure, like, I don't know, Chapel Rhone or like a performer or an idol of ours or even a friend who just seriously has no, just doesn't have that war, doesn't have that war between them and the world. So why exactly is it the case that we do?
为什么有些人有这种恐惧，而其他人却没有？有些人哪怕有一点点害怕以最完整、最真实的自我存在，我们都会由衷地钦佩他们。我确信我们现在脑海中都有这样一个人。也许是一个流行文化人物，比如，我不知道，查佩尔·罗恩（Chappell Roan）或者某个表演者、我们的偶像，甚至是一个朋友，他们真的毫无畏惧，只是没有那堵墙，没有他们与世界之间的那堵墙。那么，为什么偏偏我们会有呢？
Is this fear? Where does this worry of being perceived truly come from? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
这种恐惧？这种对被注视的担忧到底从何而来？2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家对话，
to look past the impractical and way to... too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you.
去拨开那些主导了整个健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌失措的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。搜索数字“2%”，即可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的
get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim?
任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不在乎黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。
To be clear, 84's big two, me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
澄清一下，对我和来说，84年意义重大不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备在哪天聊聊霹雳可卡因，只是为了让你们大家都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。现在我们还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对于黑人来说，还有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. You get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师——凯尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们仍在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你成为好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《知难而进》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出了她故事中前后矛盾的明显破绽。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了一场长达数年的官司，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我整个人惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，
is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Firstly, our fear of being perceived is really closely linked to, of course, social anxiety and anxiety in general, as most social and specific phobias are. What I really want people to know is that social anxiety is more than just shyness. It's more than just introversion. It's actually a complex difference in how our brains are reacting.
这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。首先，我们对被注视的恐惧与社交焦虑以及一般意义上的焦虑紧密相连，大多数社交恐惧症和特定恐惧症都是如此。我真正想让大家知道的是，社交焦虑不仅仅是害羞。它不仅仅是内向。它实际上是我们的脑子在如何对环境做出反应方面的一种复杂差异，
to our environment, including social interactions, and specifically how they're wired to absorb this information and the meaning that they apply to it. Mainly, social anxiety and with its scropophobia is attributed to a dysfunction in the hippocampus, the amygdala, and the areas of our brain that process emotion, meaning that there is a lot more activity in those specific regions, making us feel more attuned to small moments, small cues, that are kind of seen through like a fearful lens. That's the easiest way to put it. There are a lot of neural mechanisms that are simply different
包括社交互动，特别是它们如何被连线来吸收这些信息以及它们赋予这些信息的意义。主要是，社交焦虑和视线恐惧症被归因于海马体、杏仁核以及我们大脑中处理情绪的区域的功能障碍，这意味着这些特定区域有更多的活动，使我们对那些通过恐惧镜头看待的小瞬间、小线索更加敏感。这是最简单的表达方式。有许多神经机制在患有社交焦虑的人、患有视线恐惧症的人以及没有这些症状的人之间
between people with social anxiety and people with scropophobia and people without it. And those neural mechanisms are caused by both genetics and our environment. but I think it's important that we acknowledge the neural and biological mechanisms controlling this fear at the very top of this because especially when maybe we encounter someone who just doesn't quite understand where Alfio comes from, they really need to know and I hope that they do know that a lot of it is not really within our choice. It's not something that we have opted into. Actually, it's the way that we are built. it's why we also kind of see people who care so little about others opinions and they possess zero self-awareness because they don't have that same neural makeup and those same kind of cross-activations between different regions of their brains that mean when they see a social
就是存在差异。而这些神经机制是由遗传和我们的环境共同导致的。但我认为重要的是，我们在最开始就要承认控制这种恐惧的神经和生物机制，特别是当我们可能会遇到某个并不太理解我们的恐惧从何而来的人时，他们确实需要知道，我也希望他们能知道，这很大程度上并不是我们的选择。这不是我们主动选择的结果。实际上，这就是我们的生理结构。这也是为什么我们也会看到有些人对别人的看法毫不在意，并且完全没有自我意识，因为他们不具备相同的神经结构和大脑不同区域之间那种交叉激活，这意味着当他们看到社交
situation when they see the potential for being judged their fear centres kind of light up they're hyper-aware there is none of that going on and it's kind of like the opposite side of the coin here. Like it's equally as confronting to see someone who genuinely doesn't care to a fault. But scropophobia can also arise from something really upsetting or traumatic that has happened at some point in your life, especially during childhood, especially around bullying, exclusion, isolation, public humiliation. Those events and situations can be actually quite shocking.
情境、看到被评判的潜在可能时，他们的恐惧中心根本不会亮起，他们并不超级敏感，完全没有那种情况发生，这有点像硬币的另一面。就像看到一个盲目到无所谓的人一样，同样让人感到具有冲击力。但视线恐惧症也可能源于你生命中某个阶段发生的极其令人心烦或创伤性的事件，尤其是在童年时期，特别是围绕着霸凌、排斥、孤立、公开羞辱。这些事件和情境实际上可能相当令人震惊，
and very intense, and so they leave a lifelong imprint and they cause behavioral and emotional changes. Actually, in some 40 to 60 percent of cases of scropophobia, people are able to trace their fear back to a catalyst event or a specific time in their lives when they were really going through it, when they were really socially ostracized or isolated. these situations can make us increasingly hyper aware, firstly of how others see us, because we're trying to anticipate a situation where our biggest fears could be realized again.
且非常强烈，因此它们会留下终生的印记，并导致行为和情感上的改变。事实上，在大约40%到60%的视线恐惧症病例中，人们能够将他们的恐惧追溯到一个催化事件或他们人生中的某个特定时期，那时他们确实在经历艰难，确实被社会排斥或孤立。这些情况会让我们变得越来越高度警惕，首先是警惕别人如何看待我们，因为我们试图预测那种最大的恐惧可能再次成真的情境。
We already know what this feels like. We didn't like it. And so we try and avoid anything that reminds us of a previous time when we were judged, when we were bullied, when we were excluded. And I do want to highlight bullying as an example here because it's definitely one that resonates with me a lot as like a kid who was bullied. I know I always say that I think children like that actually end up becoming quite interesting people because they learn to not, I guess not rely on the external validation of others,
我们已经知道这种感觉是什么样了。我们不喜欢它。所以我们试图避开任何让我们想起过去那些我们曾被评判、被霸凌、被排斥的时光的事物。我确实想在这里强调霸凌这个例子，因为它绝对是一个能引起我强烈共鸣的例子，作为一个曾经被霸凌的孩子。我知道我总是说，我觉得那样的孩子们最终会成为相当有趣的人，因为他们学会了不去——我想是不去依赖他人对自己的外部肯定，
but it can also make us go the complete opposite way, where that external validation of others becomes all we can think about. If you went through childhood, knowing what it felt like to be teased constantly, to have those whispers kind of follow you around online in person. And then you tried your hardest to avoid that experience by wearing the clothes that made you fit in, by staying out of the way, by appeasing your bullies, and still finding that you couldn't escape it, that pain is not something that you easily forget. And so even as you age, it doesn't go away.
但它也可能让我们走向完全相反的极端，以至于对他人外部的肯定成了我们满脑子只想的事情。如果你经历过童年，知道那种不断被戏弄、那些窃窃私语在网上和现实中如影随形的感觉是什么样。然后你尽了最大努力通过穿能让你融入群体的衣服、保持低调、顺从霸凌者来避开那种经历，却发现自己仍然无法逃脱，那种痛苦并不是那么容易忘记的。所以即使你长大了，它也不会消失。
Memories like that are interesting because from an evolutionary perspective, They're meant to help us, but they also contribute to trauma and PTSD. And in a paper published in 2011, researchers showed that harmful, painful memories typically actually have greater recall than positive memories from around the same time. So it's not like you can just forget and move on. That's like saying, oh, can you please forget what your best friend's name is? Can you forget what your first day of school was like? Can you forget your graduation?
这样的记忆很有趣，因为从进化的角度来看，它们的本意是帮助我们，但它们也会导致创伤和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。在2011年发表的一篇论文中，研究人员表明，有害的、痛苦的记忆通常比同一时期左右的积极记忆具有更高的回忆度。所以这并不是说你只要忘记就能继续前行。这就好比说：“哦，你能忘掉你最好朋友的名字吗？你能忘掉你上学第一天是什么样的吗？你能忘掉你的毕业典礼吗？”
Can you forget the many times that you didn't. feel like you belong. Can you forget the way that people's judgments made you feel? Of course we can't. It's ingrained in us. It's a permanent kind of fixture of our past and in some ways of our identity. The behaviours surrounding our fear of being perceived, scrutinized, judged, are actually based on this understanding. They become defensive based on previous experiences. The possibility of going through that situation once more is so confronting that. that we learn what we need to do to avoid it from happening. And often how we avoid it from happening is to just avoid social situations.
你能忘掉那些你觉得自己不属于那里的许多时刻吗？你能忘掉别人评判带给你的感觉吗？我们当然做不到。它已经根植于我们体内。它是我们过去的一种永久固定装置，在某种程度上也是我们身份的一部分。围绕着我们对被注视、被审视、被评判的恐惧的行为，实际上正是基于这种理解。它们根据过去的经验变成了防御性的。再次经历那种情况的可能性是如此令人难以面对，
We've kind of already talked about how that can sustain this fear of being perceived even longer. But, you know, if it's all you're trying to do to survive, if it makes you feel better in the moment, sometimes it's hard not to do those things. it's hard not to, you know, both deeply crave social approval and also be deeply terrified of it. I hope that explanation makes some sense. I also read a really fascinating article from disability rights activists that people with physical disabilities are also more likely to have a deep-rooted fear of being perceived because of again past experiences of being mocked, being pointed at, feeling those eyes on them in public, wherever they go, that constant rest of. recognition that you're being watched or that people have these private thoughts about you. I just, that would be so much to manage.
以至于我们懂得了我们需要做什么来避免它再次发生。而我们通常避免它的方式，就是直接回避社交情境。我们其实已经讨论过这会如何让这种对被注视的恐惧持续更久。但是，（你知道的）如果这成了你为了生存而做的全部努力，如果它能让你在当下感觉更好一点，有时确实很难不去这样做。很难不去（你知道的）既深深渴望社会认可，又对它感到深深的恐惧。我希望这个解释能说得通。我还读过残疾人权利活动人士的一篇非常迷人的文章，文章指出由于过去遭受嘲笑、被人指指点点、无论走到哪里都感受到公众目光的那种经历，身体有残疾的人也更有可能产生一种根深蒂固的对被注视的恐惧，那种时刻意识到自己正在被注视或人们对你有私下看法的认识。我只是觉得，要应付这一切真是太不容易了。
It would just be exhausting and very, very loud. The final thing that we have to briefly discuss here is actually perfectionism, which you may be surprised to hear come up in this kind of episode, but what we know about the fear of being perceived and what we know about perfectionism actually confirms that they are related in some very intuitive ways. Perfectionists set extremely high standards for themselves, and they are often preoccupied with avoiding mistakes, either social and nature, maybe academic,
那只会让人筋疲力尽，而且吵闹无比。我们要在这里简短讨论的最后一件事其实是完美主义，听到它出现在这种主题的节目里，你可能会觉得意外，但我们对“害怕被看见”的恐惧的了解，以及我们对完美主义的了解，其实证实了它们在某些非常直观的方面是相互关联的。完美主义者为自己设定了极高的标准，他们往往全神贯注于避免犯错，无论是社交性质的，还是学术性质的，
whatever it is that they are primarily fixated on. But this also causes them to become quite obsessed by flaws or imperfections that they believe will be noticed and criticized by others. The desire to appear perfect can create a very intense anxiety about being in the spotlight. Even if being in the spotlight is just being around other people, feeling like their eyes are on you, feeling like you have their attention, feeling like they are going to find that thing that you already know is wrong with you. Actually, this really interesting article published in psychology today, which I feel like by now you guys know is my favorite place for sources on this.
不管他们主要执着于什么。但这也会导致他们对那些他们认为会被别人注意到并批评的缺点或瑕疵变得相当着迷。渴望表现完美的愿望，会让人对处于聚光灯下产生一种非常强烈焦虑。即使处于聚光灯下仅仅是身处人群之中，感觉他们的目光正注视着你，感觉你吸引了他们的注意力，感觉他们会发现你身上那个你已经知道不对劲的地方。事实上，这篇发表在《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）上的有趣文章——我觉得你们现在已经知道这是我寻找这类素材的最爱去处了。
Actually, it was published earlier this year, and it notes that a fear of judgment or disapproval from others is actually the primary contributing factor to people managing perfectionism, and it's also one of the primary contributing factors to people with scopophobia. So in terms of like, if you were to make an organizational chart, or I guess like a way of categorizing different things that we can be going through mentally, different fears, different conditions, different whatever. Scropophobia and perfectionism and a fear of judgment, all of those three things sit very, very closely together. They're probably only delineated by like a few percentiles. Let's take a step back though, because we've kind of been circling around this question
事实上，它是在今年早些时候发表的，它指出，对他人判断或不认同的恐惧，其实是人们难以应对完美主义的主要成因，它也是患有广场恐惧症或审视恐惧症的人的主要成因之一。所以，如果我们要画一张组织架构图，或者说是一种将我们在精神上可能经历的不同事物、不同的恐惧、不同的状况、不同的种种进行分类的方法。审视恐惧症、完美主义和对判断的恐惧，这三者非常非常紧密地联系在一起。它们之间的差异可能只有百分之几的差距。不过，让我们退一步想，因为我们
for the entire episode, but why does it even really matter? why do people's opinions really matter? And I know we talked about social disapproval. I know we talked about belonging. I know we talked about perfectionism, about rejection. But truly, how life-changing is the opinion of someone we may never speak to again? How life-changing is that? What does that really have to do with us?
在这期节目的整个过程中都在盘旋着这个问题：这到底有什么重要的呢？别人的意见真的那么重要吗？我知道我们讨论了社会的不认同。我知道我们讨论了归属感。我知道我们讨论了完美主义、拒绝。但说实话，一个我们可能再也不会和他说句话的人的意见，对人生的改变到底有多大？那到底能改变多少人生？这跟我们到底有什么关系？
How is that really going to hurt us? What is it about those judgments that feel so important to us? Because, you know, if you wouldn't invite someone into your house, why do we let them into our head? The burden of this fear is kind of thrust so heavily onto us, whilst the people who, you know, are judging us, maybe not judging us, they kind of just get to go along their merry way. They never know what we're feeling, what we're changing, how we're hiding to be less seen, and it's costing you your life.
这到底怎么会伤害到我们呢？为什么那些评判对我们来说会显得如此重要？因为，你知道的，如果你不会请某个人进你的家，我们为什么要让他们进入我们的脑海呢？这种恐惧的负担几乎全都被沉重地压在我们身上，而那些正在评判我们的人——也许根本没在评判我们——他们却可以自顾自地过着他们快活的日子。他们永远不知道我们的感受是什么，我们在做怎样的改变，我们为了少被看见而如何躲藏，而这正在付出生命令你窒息的代价。
And when I say your life, I mean it's costing you your freedom, your potential, it's costing you joy, relationships, opportunities, even if it's not something that you're consciously choosing. So what we really need to discuss is how we can break through that wall that is keeping us separated from a confident, self-assured, liberated life where the opinions of others kind of glide off us. They don't take up as much mental real estate. And I really want to help you with that. So I'm going to give you three powerful exercises and mental shifts that you can try today
当我说你的代价时，我的意思是这正在剥夺你的自由、你的潜能，它剥夺了你的快乐、人际关系、各种机会，即使这不是你清醒时的主动选择。所以我们真正需要讨论的是，我们该如何打破那堵将我们与自信、笃定、解放的生活隔开的墙，在这种生活中，别人的意见会从我们身上滑落。它们不会占据那么多的心理空间。我真的很想在这方面帮到你。所以我要给你三个强有力的练习和思维转变，你今天就可以尝试，
to overcome your fear of being perceived. After this short break, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
以此来克服你对被注视的恐惧。广告之后，不见不散。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在奇特的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractors, and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，透过那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的噱头和过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击 Lil Kim 的胸部吗？或者当说出坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟 Lil Kim 到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是 Sam Jek。我是 Alex English。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他大谈特谈80年代的快克毒品。说实话，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都能聊聊快克，不过就是让你们大家知道而已。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把爱滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《The Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师 Keer Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person
有时，当我们在一往直前地追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追寻，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，
while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
当你来到人世时，或者你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，由我 Kear Games 带你进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她谎言中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。
Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our fear of being perceived is built on a foundation of irrational thoughts as most anxious patterns are. The irrational thoughts associated with our scopophobia sound like this. Everyone is constantly judging me. People will remember every awkwardly thing that I do. If they don't like me, my life is over. If they don't think I'm funny, charming, good looking, they'll tell everyone and I'll lose all my friends. If these people at the party judge me, no one will speak to me anymore. These beliefs have probably helped you in the past stay away from situations that you thought were threatening or made you uncomfortable. But now
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。我们对被注视的恐惧建立在不理性的想法的基础之上，就像大多数焦虑的模式一样。与我们的审视恐惧症相关的不理性想法听起来是这样的：每个人都在无时无刻地评判我。人们会记住我做的每一个尴尬的举动。如果他们不喜欢我，我的人生就完蛋了。如果他们觉得我不好笑、没魅力、不好看，他们会告诉所有人，我会失去所有的朋友。如果派对上的这些人评判我，就不会有人再跟我说话了。这些信念过去可能曾帮助你远离了那些你认为具有威胁性或让你感到不舒服的情况。但现在
they're just not useful anymore. And you know that because you're listening to this episode. episode. The easiest way to deal with anxious thoughts like these is not to try and suppress them, ignore them, or even overthink your way out of them. It's to play the game, the game of hypothetical that your anxiety is so great at. Every time you think that someone is judging you, tell yourself that they are actually admiring you, because why can't that be the case? what makes either of those scenarios more likely than the other. The fear-based scenario feels more likely because we're used to thinking that it's true. But is it?
它们已经没用了。你知道这一点，因为你正在收听这期节目。应对此类焦虑想法最简单的方法，不是试图压制它们、忽视它们，甚至不是过度思考来摆脱它们。而是玩这个游戏——你的焦虑最擅长的假设游戏。每当你觉得有人在评判你时，告诉自己其实他们是在欣赏你，因为为什么不能是这样呢？是什么让这两种情况中的哪一种比另一种更有可能发生？基于恐惧的那种情况感觉更有可能发生，因为我们习惯了认为它是真的。但真的是吗？
You might think, well, based on past experiences it is, but how many more times have people been able to perceive you and really loved your outfit or thought that you were really interesting or loved your smile and just not said anything? How many more times have people just. not noticed you at all, never thought about you again, the same way that you have noticed people or not noticed people and never thought about them again. There is this idea in psychology that we pay more attention to the situations that already confirmed bias for us. The bias in this
你可能会想，嗯，根据过去的经验确实如此，但有多少次，人们能够注意到你，却真的非常喜欢你的外套，或者觉得你真的很有趣，或者喜欢你的微笑，只是什么都没说？又有多少次，人们只是完全没有注意到你，从来没有再想起过你，就像你注意到过别人或没有注意到别人，却从来没有再想起过他们一样。心理学上有一种观点，我们总是更加关注那些已经证实了我们偏见的场景。这里的偏见是
situation is everyone is judging me. But it actually means that we don't see the full spectrum of all the other times that hasn't been the case. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. you know, whether that person is judging you or not, if you get into the habit of playing mind games with your mind games, it can be as simple as hearing that thought pop up, visualizing it, and having a laugh at yourself. Like, that's so funny. What a funny piece of false news my brain is trying to tell me. I have no evidence to suggest that in this moment that person is judging me more than they are admiring me, more than they think that I am cool or funny or lovely. So that is our first mental shift, recognizing that you may think you know what's running through
每个人都在评判我。但这实际上意味着我们没有看到所有其他不属于这种情况的大量情况。没关系。没关系，你知道的，不管那个人是不是在评判你，如果你养成了用心理游戏对付自己心理游戏的习惯，这可以很简单，只要听到那个想法冒出来，将其可视化，然后嘲笑自己一下。就像，太好笑了。我的大脑试图告诉我的是多么搞笑的一条假新闻啊。没有任何证据表明此时此刻那个人评判我的程度超过了他们欣赏我的程度，超过了他们觉得我很酷、很有趣、很可爱的程度。所以这是我们的第一个思维转变，认识到你可能以为自己知道某人的脑海里在想什么，
someone's head, but maybe you don't. And as always, quite frankly, it's none of your business. That's their problem. And what kind of a sad, frustrating life it would be if this person were to be judging you, not really knowing you, and if for their whole life all they do is just see the worse than someone. If that is what that person's reality is, how miserable, would that be? How just plain dark to see someone existing and to just have your mind immediately find something to scrutinize? What I'm trying to get at is that it says a lot more about them
但也许你并不知道。而且就像往常一样，坦率地说，这根本不管你的事。那是他们的问题。如果这个人真的在评判你，却并不真正了解你，而且如果他们的一生中除了看到别人糟糕的一面之外什么都不做，那将是多么悲惨、多么令人沮丧的人生啊。如果那是那个人的现实，该有多凄凉啊？仅仅看到一个人存在，而你的大脑就会立即找到一些东西来进行挑剔，那是多么黑暗啊？我想表达的是，这更多地说明了他们自己，
and they have a lot of bigger things to worry about than what you may or may not be doing because their head is probably a really dark, insecure place and what a sad reality for them. I also find it useful if I'm still being met with the persistent thought that they're judging me, that they don't like me, to instead give that, to just kind of look at that hypothetical assessment and instead of being like I'm going to internalize their potential hatred of me, their potential disgust or embarrassment of me, I'm going to assume that that's what they're feeling and that's fine, And then I'm just going to flood them with unconditional love.
而且他们有比你可能在做或没有在做的事情多得多的重大问题要担心，因为他们的脑海里可能是一个非常黑暗、没有安全感的地方，对他们来说这是多么悲惨的现实啊。我还发现，如果我仍然遇到那种坚持认为他们在评判我、他们不喜欢我的想法时，换个方式很有用，就是去审视那种假设的评估，而不是像我要内化他们对我的潜在憎恶、他们对我潜在的厌恶或尴尬那样，我要假设那是他们的感受，而这没关系，然后我只需用无条件爱充满他们。
In my mind, I'm going to look at this person. I'm going to perceive, think about this person. And I'm just going to imagine just shooting, like, just literally covering them in this big blanket of empathy and love from me. And it really does help you be like, I don't know, I guess in my mind, I'm just like, it helps you see that this person might be thinking. the worst in you and still going beyond not caring, being so defiant that you still like decide to give them love and you still decide to give them empathy what they're going through. And that act of being the bigger person makes you realize that this person is not inherently better than you, not inherently, doesn't inherently know more than you.
在我的脑海里，我要看着这个人。我要感知、思考这个人。而我只想象着向他们倾泻——字面意思，就是用我的一大片同理心和爱把他们包裹起来。它确实能帮你，我不知道，我想在我的脑海里，我只是觉得，它能帮你看到这个人可能在想着你最坏的一面，而你却超越了不在乎，变得如此叛逆，以至于你仍然决定给予他们爱，并且你仍然决定对他们所经历的事情给予同理心。而那种表现得更大度、更成熟的行为，让你意识到这个人本质上并不比你更好，本质上并没有，本质上并不比你知道得更多。
Their opinion doesn't inherently mean more than yours. because you're still here showing this great generous gift of loving them despite the fact that they could be really cruel to you in their mind. If that isn't working, I have another mental shift of you, and it's called the yes and shift. And no, it's not the Ariana Grande song, but honestly, it's kind of a similar theme. The thing about anxious thoughts is that they feel quite real
他们的意见本质上并不比你的更有分量，因为你依然在这里展现出这种巨大而慷慨的礼物——去爱他们，尽管他们在脑海里对你非常残酷。如果这不管用，我还有另一种思维转变，它被称为“是的，而且”转变。不，这不是 Ariana Grande 的歌，但老实说，主题有点相似。焦虑想法的特点在于它们感觉相当真实，
because they are like almost identical to a real. but they're incomplete. They aren't fully formed and that's what causes them to feel so scary. This is the example I always give. It's like if you were to walk into a house and it looks like a house from the outside but the kitchen and the bedroom had no walls, you'd feel really exposed in a house like that and the same goes for an anxious thought. When you walk into an anxious thought and it's not entirely complete or real, you feel exposed to the possibilities that could fill those gaps, like being ostracized, being criticized. Here's how we overcome that. We overcome that by filling in those gaps ourselves before we let our anxiety do it for us, using our yes and method. So say you're
因为它们几乎与真实情况一模一样，但它们是不完整的。它们没有完全成形，而这正是让它们感觉如此可怕的原因。这是我总是举的例子。就像如果你走进一栋房子，从外面看它像一栋房子，但厨房和卧室没有墙，你在那样的房子里会感到非常暴露，焦虑的想法也是如此。当你走进一个并不完全完整或真实的焦虑想法时，你会感到自己暴露在那些能够填补这些空白的可能性中，比如被排挤、被批判。这就是我们克服它的方法。我们通过自己在让焦虑代劳之前亲手填补这些空白来克服它，使用我们的“是的，而且”方法。所以假设你
at a party and you think someone is smirking at you or your behavior or cringing at you, talking to their friends about you. In your brain, everything is probably a light and a alive and rushing and scary and freaky. And you're probably thinking they don't like me. Now, what I want you to do here is accept that, yeah, maybe they don't like you. And then I want you to add an end onto that sentence. They don't like me and I'll be okay anyways. They don't like me and I know my friends love me, so I'm not too fussed by that. They don't like me and I'll never see them again. So it really, that's fine by me. don't let your fear grab onto that emptiness, that unknown space, that uncertainty, and spiral.
在派对上，你觉得有人在对你或你的行为假笑，或者对你感到尴尬，在和他们的朋友谈论你。在你的大脑里，一切可能都是一团火热、鲜活、急促而可怕的。你可能在想他们不喜欢我。现在，我想让你做的是接受这一点，是的，也许他们真的不喜欢你。然后我想让你在那句话后面加上一个“而且”。他们不喜欢我，但我 anyway 也会没事的。他们不喜欢我，但我知道我的朋友们爱我，所以我对此并不是很纠结。他们不喜欢我，而且我再也不会见到他们了。所以这真的，这对我来说很好。不要让你的恐惧抓住那种空虚感、未知空间、不确定性，然后螺旋式上升。
Because if you let your fear take over the end, it will sound something like, they don't like me, and that means that everyone at this party doesn't like me, and that means that maybe I shouldn't leave. So you kind of get where that ends up taking you. It takes you into a place of withdrawal and isolation, meaning you never face the fear. But what we really need to do is condition our mind to make peace with our fear of being perceived by replacing the worst case scenario that we so quickly jump to with a reaffirming statement or conclusion that really builds us up, that de-centers the opinion of this other person, and that makes us feel confident in whatever circumstance is about to occur. our final mental shift that we're going to discuss, I've come to call the mastery shift. And it's based on principles of exposure therapy that are very often used to desensitized people
因为如果你让恐惧接管了“而且”后面的内容，它听起来就会像这样：他们不喜欢我，这意味着这个派对上的每个人都不喜欢我，这意味着也许我不该离开。所以你大概能明白这最终会把你带向何方。它会把你带入一个退缩和孤立的境地，这意味着你永远不会直面恐惧。但我们真正需要做的是，通过用能够肯定我们自己、降低这个人的意见的权重、并让我们在即将发生任何情况下都感到自信的肯定性陈述或结论，来取代我们如此迅速跳进的最坏情况，从而让我们的心态习惯于与对被注视的恐惧人和解。我们将要讨论的最后一个思维转变，我称之为掌控转变。它基于暴露疗法的原理，这种疗法非常常用于使患有
with phobia from their fears. And it's used for things like a fear of snakes, a fear of planes, fear of bees. And we can use it for a fear of being perceived. So this is what I want you to do. I want you to make a list of 10 things that your fear. fear of being perceived is preventing you from doing. And I want you to order that list from the thing that you are most afraid to do that you cannot even imagine doing in a million years to the thing you feel a little bit worried about, but you could try to borrow with enough support,
各种恐惧症的人对他们的恐惧脱敏。它被用于诸如害怕蛇、害怕飞机、害怕蜜蜂之类的事情。我们可以用它来应对害怕被注视。所以这是我想让你做的。我想让你列出10件你的害怕被注视的恐惧正在阻止你去做的事情。我想让你把这张清单按事情进行排序，从你最害怕做、以至于在几百万年里连想都不敢想的事情，排到你觉得有一点担心、但在有足够的支持、
with enough affirmations, with a really good dose of confidence. So I'll give you some examples of what could be on that list. Starting really small, it could be, um, recording. like a short video of yourself, talking about a topic and watching it back. It could be posting something you really want to post on social media on a private account, wearing an outfit that's bright or more out there than usual on public transport, wearing something that you know that you're shy to wear, offering to give a small speech at a friend's birthday, planning an event where you're going to be the centre of attention like a birthday party, going up to a group at a party who you don't know and introducing yourself, doing a huge presentation at work.
有足够的肯定、有强大自信的情况下你可以尝试去做的事情。所以我来给你举一些那个清单上可能会有的例子的。从非常小的事情开始，它可以是，嗯，录制一段关于某个话题的自己的短视频并回看它。它可以在私人账号上发布一些你真的很想在社交媒体上发布的内容，在公共交通工具上穿着一套比平时更亮眼或更出挑的服装，穿着一件你知道自己会害羞去穿的衣服，主动在朋友的生日上发表简短的讲话，策划一个你会成为全场焦点的活动，比如生日派对，走到派对上一个你不认识的群体中并自我介绍，在工作中做一个大型演讲。
What we want to do is start small. Start with those really small things. Like posting something on a private Instagram. Even if it's like for 24 hours, post a story, post a story to your close friends, just something really, really small. Wear that outfit, wear like the thing that you would never wear. And once you can get through that situation without feeling true. ghastly or anxious, you move on to the next. We want to build up your tolerance basically
我们想做的是从小事做起。从那些非常小的事情开始。比如在私人 Instagram 上发布一些内容。即使只是发布24小时，发布一个快拍，向你的密友发布一个快拍，只是一些非常非常小的事情。穿那套衣服，穿那种你绝对不会穿的衣服。一旦你能够度过那种情况而不会感到真正的可怕或焦虑，你就进入下一阶段。我们基本上希望建立你对被看到、
to being seen, maybe being heard, being watched, perhaps even being judged. By showing you that A, rarely is the worst case scenario going to be the one that happens. B, even if it is, repeat after me, you will be okay. You will be okay. And finally, it starts to show you the possibility of a life without the fear of being perceived being the only thing that is motivating you. Finally, and one bonus shift that has helped me immensely in the past few years that I don't really have a name for, let's call it the ideal self-shift, is really focused on tuning into what do you actually want. I think one of the consequences of a fear of being perceived that we haven't spoken about is that we are always thinking about how to be less offensive to others,
也许被听到、被注视、甚至可能被评判的耐受力。通过向你证明：A，最坏情况发生的情况很少；B，即使真的发生了，重复我说的，你会没事的。你会没事的。最后，它开始向你展示一种生活的可能性——在这种生活中，对被注视的恐惧不再是唯一驱使你的动力。最后，还有一个额外的好处，在过去几年里对我有极大的帮助，我其实给它起不出名字，我们就叫它理想自我转变吧，它真正专注于调整到你真正想要的是什么。我认为，我们没有谈论过的对被注视的恐惧的后果之一，就是我们总是在思考如何对他人不那么具有攻击性、
what they might expect from us, how to make us likable based on their tastes, their views, their ideals. It's, you know, hugely aligned with people placing, but it also disconnects us from what we need ourselves and who we want to be, because it's all about making others happy. De-prioritize the thoughts of others just for five minutes. What do you think about your What do you think about yourself and is that good enough for you such that in five years time you would be okay with still being this version of you? I really want you to sit with that for a second. If no one else was around, who would you be?
他们可能对我们有什么期望、如何根据他们的品味、他们的观点、他们的理想来让我们变得讨人喜欢。这，你知道的，在很大程度上与讨好他人是一致的，但它也将我们与我们自己真正需要的东西以及我们想成为什么样的人隔绝开来，因为这一切都是为了让别人开心。把别人的想法降权，哪怕就五分钟。你对自己怎么看？你对自己的看法觉得好吗？对你来说足够好，以至于在五年后你依然能接受自己依然是这个版本的你吗？我真的很想让你就这个问题静心思考一秒钟。如果周围没有其他人，你会是谁？
Would you like this version of you? How would you dress? How would you go about your daily life? What is your potential? and what's stopping you from being those things right now. Now I want you to think about what things you'd like to change and I want you to kind of decide which of those things that you are hell-bent on changing
你会喜欢这个版本的自己吗？你会怎么穿衣打扮？你会如何过你的日常生活？你的潜能是什么？是什么在阻止你现在就成为那些事情。现在我想让你思考你想改变哪些事情，我想让你大致决定一下，你坚决要改变的、或者你认为会让你快乐的那些事情中，有哪些是基于你认为别人对你的期望，以及你需要为了他们的认可而改变的。然后我也想让你承认你想改变什么，因为你想改。你想要为你的生活、属于你的生活改变什么？当你看着这两列事情——你需要改变的事情，或者你需要成为什么样的人——当你看到那些你觉得为了别人而需要成为的样子，以及当你看到那些你觉得
or you think would make you happy are based on what you think other people expect from you and what you need to change for their approval. And then I also want you to acknowledge what you want to change because you want to. what do you want to change for your life, the life that is yours? And when you look at those two columns of things that you feel you need to change or who you need to be and you see the things that you feel you need to be for others and you see the things that you feel
需要成为并且你想为了自己而成为的样子时，每当你发现自己把过多的精力集中在左边那一栏时，我希望你重新转回右边。把你的全部精力集中在第二栏上：我为自己想要什么，我为自己想要的生活，我没有这种恐惧可以成为的人，并把它当作一个提醒，每当你担心或痴迷于某人对你的看法或没有看法时。因为你是你所有体验、你整个宇宙的中心，你才是这里最重要的人，我希望你坚定不移地致力于成为最真实的自己，即使它让人感觉自私。你是世界。自私或者像是你在让别人失望。
the need to be and you want to be for yourself, any time you find yourself focusing too much on that left-hand column, I want you to shift back to the right. concentrate all of your energy on that second column, what I want for me, the life I want for me, the person I can become without this fear, and keep it as a reminder for when you're worrying or obsessing over what someone does or doesn't think about you. Because you are the center of all your experiences, of your whole universe, you are the one that matters here, and I want you to be fiercely devoted to being your truest self, even if it feels self. You're the world. selfish or like you're disappointing others.
这是一块肌肉，从对被注视的恐惧中恢复。是一块肌肉，它是一项技能，它是我们能学习的最伟大的技能之一，因为它将彻底改变你的生活。请听我说这句话。这很难。当你处于这种恐惧状态如此之久时，它会感觉很不自然。但你终有一天会拥有的那种自由感，让这一切都变得非常值得。我真的不认为你需要在余生中都这么害怕。
This is a muscle, healing from our fear of being perceived. Is a muscle, it's a skill, and it's one of the greatest skills we can learn because it will transform your life. Please hear me when I say this. It's hard. It feels unnatural when you have been in this fearful state for so long. But just the sense of freedom that you're one day going to have makes it so worth it. I really don't think that you need to be this fearful for the rest of your life.
即使你现在觉得这种恐惧在保护你，或者它是有用的、有帮助的，我想你大概也知道事实已经不再如此了，因为你在这里，你正在收听这期节目，而且你想改变你的生活。我认为一旦你致力于此，一旦你降低他人意见的权重，一旦你找到了适合你的思维转变、适合你的心理游戏，这一切都会成为可能。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真的希望你们喜欢它。我希望你们学到了一些东西。
Even if you feel like right now this fear is protecting you or that it's useful or it's helpful, I think you kind of know that it's no longer the case because you're here and you're listening to this episode and you want to change your life. And I think that that is something that once you are committed to, once you deprioritize the opinions of others, once you find the mental shift the mental game that works for you, it all becomes possible. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I do really hope that you enjoyed it. I hope that you learned something.
我希望你们能从中有所收获。我希望你们能摆脱对被注视的恐惧。你可以把它扔掉。你可以把其他人仅仅看作是做他们自己事情的其他人，就像你在做你自己的事情一样。并且真正去去做那些事情——去冒险，去体验那些让你害怕、并且因为别人可能会怎么想而一直让你害怕的事情。而希望现在你已经不在乎了。所以，如果你认识某个人，你觉得
I hope that you can take something away. I hope that you can get rid of your fear of being perceived. You can toss it out. That you can just look at other people as just other people doing their own thing the same way that you're doing your own thing. And really do the things. do the adventures, do the experiences that scare you and that have always scared you because of what others might think. And hopefully now you don't care. So if there is someone that you know who you think
他们可能需要听听这期节目，请随时与他们分享，在网上分享，在 Instagram 上分享。如果你有额外的想法、感受，或者我不知道，各种假设，你也可以发私信联系我。你可以在 That Psychology Podcast 给我们发私信。我们目前也接受节目建议，并确保在 Spotify 或 Apple 上关注我们，如果你喜欢这期节目，请给我们一个五星好评。直到下一次，保持温柔，善待自己，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《The Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人把他的朋友们带入武装。
might need to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them, share it online, share it on Instagram. You can also DM me if you have additional thoughts, feelings, I don't know, hypotheticals. You can DM me at That Psychology Podcast. We're also taking episode suggestions at the moment and make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple and give us a five-star review if you enjoyed this episode. Until next time, stay gentle, be kind to yourself and we will be talking very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 AHA 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the hard way》。
what he's doing. How many men carry his friends? to the armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在奇特的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO.%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是 Sam J.，我是 Alex English。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何平台上收听 "Look Back At It"。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。